je
bonjour à tous il ya des philosophes
dans l'histoire dont on retient le nom
que ce soit parce que leur pensée à
influencé leur époque et les générations
futures
soit parce que leurs oeuvres étaient
suffisamment original atypique
innovantes pour être remarqués et
traverser l'épreuve du temps de ce point
de vue là on peut dire que vous saurez
unit les deux conditions
l' influence de rousseau a été
grandissante du temps de son vivant
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
on souhaitait un auteur particulièrement
atypique tellement atypique que on
hésite parfois à le classer dans le
mouvement des lumières auquel il
appartient pourtant historiquement en
effet rousseau est un auteur du xviiie
siècle un auteur connu pour avoir
défendu un régime politique basée sur la
volonté du peuple et l'intérêt général
autrement dit un projet on ne peut plus
progressistes pour l'époque
et pourtant sur de nombreux aspects
rousseau est plutôt considéré comme un
conservateur et ça s'explique assez bien
rousseau est quelqu'un de très critique
envers la modernité il est très critique
envers cette idéologie du progrès qu'on
trouve dans la pensée des lumières
c'est quelqu'un par exemple qu'il ne
partageait pas l'optimisme d'un voltaire
on sait que voltaire faisait l'éloge de
la modernité de la modernité libérale
l'éloge de la connaissance l'éloge de la
civilisation l'éloge de la prospérité
économique et entre rousseau et voltaire
il ya eu un conflit extrêmement profond
à conflits idéologiques mais aussi
personnelle au point que la légende
raconte que voltaire aurait tenté de
faire assassiner rosso elle retrouve des
éléments contradictoires sur cette
affaire est ce qui est certain c'est que
voltaire et rousseau n'avait pas de mots
assez durs l'un contre l'autre et ce
conflit illustre parfaitement
l'opposition entre le progressisme des
lumières progressisme voltairien et le
conservatisme de rousseau qui n'est pas
un conservatisme politique mais qui est
simplement l'attachement à des valeurs
ancestrales l'attachement à une certaine
tradition l'attachement à un idéal qui
selon rousseau a été anéantie par la
modernité c'est l'idéal antique l'idéal
guerrier et l'idéal du courage de la
vertu de toutes ces valeurs morales qui
structurent l éducation dans l'antiquité
et dont rousseau a la nostalgie parce
qu'ils pensent que la modernité ne
valorise pas à la vertu ne valorise pas
l'héroïsme guerrier il a l'impression
que la modernité favorise au contraire
l'égoïsme favorise l'hypocrisie favori
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le règne de la
représentation le règne de l'image le
règne du faux
et c'est ça qui fait de rousseau un
auteur assez atypique car c'est un
auteur des lumières contre les lumières
pour ne pas être confondus avec des
auteurs tels que montesquieu tels que
diderot ou tel que voltaire c'est
vraiment un auteur qui va développer une
pensée personnelle et d'ailleurs pour
illustrer ce caractère qu'on appellerait
aujourd'hui antisystème de rousseau je
vais vous lire une simple phrase qui est
extraite de sa préface au discours sur
les sciences et les arts
et qui dit je ne me soucie guère de
plaire ni aux beaux esprits ni aux gens
à la mode
il y aura dans tous les temps des hommes
fait pour être subjugué par les opinions
de leur siècle
cette phrase illustre parfaitement
l'anticonformisme de rousseau dont il
semblait bien que la plus grande hantise
la plus grande angoisse
c'était d'être considéré comme un homme
de son temps c'était d'être considéré
comme un homme qui épousait le discours
de son temps et ça c'est quelque chose
dont rousseau s'est toujours tenu
éloigné le conformisme intellectuel la
consensualité intellectuelle pour sow
c'était vraiment la pire des déchéances
et ce désir de marginalité ce désir de
démarcation vis-à-vis de la pensée de
son temps va faire de rousseau un
personnage pour le moins polémique mais
aussi qui va nous apporter un regard
très précieux sur une autre manière
d'être progressiste un progressisme qui
ne va pas renier l'héritage du passé qui
ne va pas considérer que tout ce qui est
passé est dépassé un progressisme qui va
s'appuyer se nourrir des valeurs des
traditions et des vertus de l'antiquité
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
mérite d'être souligné parce que ça fait
partie intégrante de la personnalité de
rousseau et de la substance de son
oeuvre
cet idéal de vertus antique cet idéal de
beauté cet idéal de pureté qui permet de
comprendre la version de rousseau à
l'égard de la corruption à l'égard du
mensonge à l'égard du faux
alors pour entrer maintenant sur
l'aspect un peu plus technique rousseau
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle les
théoriciens du contrat social alors
qu'est ce que c'est que le contrat
social
la théorie du contractualisme c'est
l'idée que les êtres humains ont créé la
société car la société leur permettait
d'échanger une part de leur liberté
contre la sécurité
autrement dit en confiant leur liberté à
l'état les citoyens certes donne le
pouvoir à l'état mais en contrepartie ça
sur la protection de l'état
c'est ça le principe du contrat social
donc le contrat social part toujours de
l'hypothèse d'un état de nature
c'est-à-dire d'un état initial de la
condition humaine et à qui se
caractérise par l'absence d'organisation
politique l'absence d'autorité politique
donc l'absence d'état et qui selon les
auteurs va prendre différentes formes
alors par exemple chéops dont on a parlé
dans la vidéo sur machiavel chéops les
hommes sont intrinsèquement mauvais
intrinsèquement égoïste et rappelez-vous
dans la vidéo sur machiavel on avait
parlé d'un pessimisme anthropologique le
pessimisme anthropologique c'est l'idée
que la nature humaine est
fondamentalement mauvaise qu'on ne peut
rien attendre de l'homme qu'on ne peut
pas compter sur sa vertu ou sur sa
bienveillance et que c'est d'ailleurs
parce que l'homme est mauvais par nature
et parce qu'il est violent à l'égard de
ses semblables que l'instauration de
l'état est apparu comme une nécessité
pour éviter tout simplement que les
hommes ne sont reçus l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme
en l'absence d'état les hommes
s'entretuent pour se déposséder les uns
les autres de ce qu'il possède
et si les hommes avait continué comme ça
il aurait fini par s'entretuer
donc c'est parce que les hommes on
développait une crainte de la mort
violente a peur d'être tués qu'ils ont
décidé de passer un pacte qu'ils ont
décidé de nouer un contrat et ce contrat
consiste à dire nous renonçons à la
violence les uns envers les autres
nous renonçons à nous entretuer pour
prendre ce que le voisin avec nous
n'avons pas nous confions notre liberté
un souverain un entité qui détient le
pouvoir et en contrepartie l'état sur
notre sécurité ils nous protègent par
les lois par la force publique par la
justice et c'est ce qui fait que les
êtres humains vont pouvoir coexister de
manière pacifique et qu'ils vont ainsi
pouvoir s'appuyer les uns sur les autres
comme c'est le cas dans toute société
qui fonctionne
donc l'idée qui est au fondement du
contrat social c'est que les hommes ont
plus de pouvoir
lorsqu'ils sont associés que lorsqu'ils
sont seuls le fait de s'associer le fait
de se rassembler ça va augmenter notre
pouvoir d'agir sur le monde
ça va augmenter notre emprise matériel
sur le monde
c'est ça l'idée qui est à la base du
contrat social c'est l'idée que
l'association est bénéfique pour les
hommes bénéfique au niveau individuel et
au niveau collectif et chez rousseau on
trouve aussi une théorie du contrat
social d'ailleurs du contrat social
c'est le titre d'un des ouvrages de
rousseau
mais la différence entre rousseau et hop
tu sais que rousseau va partir d'une
définition de la nature humaine en
totale opposition avec la définition de
rops pour hop on l'a vu l'homme est
fondamentalement mauvais
fondamentalement égoïste et c'est ce qui
justifie selon l'ops d'ailleurs que
l'état soit autoritaire que l'état soit
impitoyable qu'il est ce qu'il appelle
le monopole de la violence légitime
parce que l'état doit détenir la force
pour pouvoir sévir pour pouvoir punir
pour pouvoir sanctionner pour pouvoir
condamner donc l'autoritarisme de l'état
chéops répond à cette nature violente et
égoïste de l'être humain
alors que cheyrou sow pas du tout chez
rousseau c'est l'exact opposé
pour rousseau l'état de nature c'est au
contraire l'état de la bonté originel
l'état de nature c'est l'état de
l'innocence c'est l'état de ce que
rousseau appelle la compassion naturelle
autrement dit pour rousseau l'homme
n'est pas du tout mauvais par nature au
contraire l'homme est bon par nature
mais n'est pas bon au sens où il aurait
été éduqués dans des valeurs morales il
n'est pas bon au sens où il aurait
appris la vertu il est bon au sens où la
vertu serait l'état originel de l'être
humain
il est bon au sens où l'homme à l'état
de nature n'a pas encore été corrompue
par la civilisation n'a pas encore été
perverti par l'individualisme sociale
mais juste avant d'aller plus loin je
dois préciser que dans cette vidéo on va
concentrer notre analyse sur un ouvrage
qui n'est pas le plus connu de rousseau
qui s'appelle le discours sur les
sciences et les arts qui est un petit
livre d'une cinquantaine de pages à
peine d'ailleurs que vous trouverez en
version audio sur youtube qui dure moins
d'une heure donc très facile à lire ou à
écouter et c'est un petit livre que
rousseau a écrit lorsqu'il av
38 ans en 1750 dans le cadre d'un
concours pour l'académie de dijon et
dont la thèse consistait à dire que le
progrès des sciences et des arts dans
l'histoire c'est à dire le progrès des
connaissances avait eu pour effet ou en
tout cas s'était accompagnée d'une
dégradation des moeurs une dégradation
des valeurs morales une dégradation de
ses vertus que rousseau chérit tant et
qui selon lui constitue une sorte
d'effet mécanique du progrès des
connaissances pour rousseau la perte de
vertu la perte des valeurs morales la
perte de cette innocence naturel est
directement liée à l'augmentation de nos
connaissances et à l'augmentation du
confort de vie qui découlent de ses
connaissances
alors évidemment on va rentrer dans le
détail on va voir précisément ce que
rousseau reproche aux sciences et aux
arts c'est à dire ce qu'il reproche à la
connaissance d'une manière générale mais
déjà il faut constater à quel point la
thèse de rousseau va faire réagir la
plupart des penseurs des lumières qui au
contraire considèrent que la
connaissance que le progrès des sciences
que le progrès des arts a contribué à
émanciper l'homme a contribué à sortir
l'homme de l'état de tutelle comme
disait quand c'est très spécial pour
l'époque c'est très spécial de
considérer que le progrès des
connaissances a eu un effet
objectivement négatif c'est très spécial
de considérer que l'augmentation des
connaissances n'a pas apporté plus de
liberté aux hommes est d'ailleurs
rousseau le dit très explicitement il
dit je cite tandis que le gouvernement
et les lois pourvoit à la sûreté au
bien-être des hommes assembler les
sciences les lettres et les arts -
despotique et plus puissants peut-être
étendent des d'irlande de fleurs sur les
chaînes de fer dont ils sont chargés
étouffant ne le sentiment de cette
liberté originel pour laquelle il
semblait être né leur font aimer leur
esclavage est en forme ce qu'on appelle
des peuples police est alors là y aurait
énormément de choses à dire et la
première d'entre elles c'est que
contrairement à la plupart de ses
contemporains où je ne considère pas la
connaissance comme quelque chose qui
guident nécessairement vers le progrès
alors certes la connaissance permet
d'augmenter notre bien-être c'est le
terme que rousseau utilise le bien-être
c'est à dire le confort de vie mais le
problème de ce confort de vie nous dit
rousseau
c'est qu'il nous ramolli c'est qu'il
nous fait perdre cette vigueur cette
résistance de l'être humain originel de
l'être humain à l'état de nature qui ne
peut compter que sur sa force sur son
courage et sur sa vertu pour survivre
pour rousseau si l'homme à l'état de
nature et plus vertueux que l'homme
moderne c'est tout simplement parce que
à l'état de nature
l'homme est obligé d'être courageux
l'homme est obligé d'être vertueux
l'homme ne peut pas se cacher derrière
l'hypocrisie sociale il ne peut pas se
cacher derrière l'intriguent la
manipulation il est obligé d'assumer le
poids du réel il est obligé d'en assumer
les contraintes et s'il n'assume pas ses
contraintes là et disparaît c'est aussi
simple que ça la nature ne se pose pas
la question de savoir quel est le statut
social ou quelle est la réputation de
tel ou tel individu
le problème de la réputation il apparaît
quand on a résolu le problème de la
survie pas avant donc tous rosso nous
sommes tous des dépravés nous sommes
tous des dépravés parce que nous vivons
dans une société de confort dans
laquelle nous n'avons pas besoin d'être
courageux vertueux et vigoureux on n'a
pas besoin est en réalité c'est même ça
le drame de l'histoire c'est que souvent
le plus courageux ou le plus vertueux
sera complètement écrasé dans la société
moderne
il sera ridiculiser sera marginalisé il
sera neutralisée par ceux qui possèdent
le meilleur statut dans la société par
exemple la classe bourgeoise et la
bourgeoisie c'est vraiment ce que
rousseau vomi c'est vraiment ce que
rousseau mais prise au plus haut point
parce qu'ils méprisent l'hypocrisie
parce qu'ils méprisent l'attachement à
l'image l'attachement à la
représentation
l'attachement au statut au singh à la
position car pour lui tous ces avantages
sont des avantages artificielle créée
par des hommes qui ont perdu toute vertu
créé par des hommes qui n'ayant plus la
force d'imposer le respect ne pouvant
plus se faire respecter par leur
exemplarité haut parleurs héroïsme vont
utiliser les armes du faible
c'est-à-dire la manigance et la
manipulation tout ce qui se trouve aux
antipodes de l'idéal vertueux de l'idéal
héroïque de l'idéal antique
pour rousseau c'est à l'état de nature
que l'homme est bon ce n'est pas à
l'état civil n'est pas à l'état social
parce que l'état social c'est l'état de
l'apprentissage des bonnes manières
c'est l'état de l'apprentissage des
codes des conventions des usages qui
font qu'on va être
accepter qu'on va être intégré dans la
société mais qu'ils sont que des russes
formelle qui ne sont que des faux
semblants les conventions sociales pour
rousseau ce sont les ombres dans la
caverne de platon
ce sont des images qui n'ont aucune
autre valeur que d'être des images
tandis que l'homme à l'état de nature et
doit affronter les prédateurs il doit
affronter les intempéries
et si l'homme ne sait pas se défendre
contre cette hostilité de la nature si
l'homme ne s'est pas survivre si l'homme
n'est pas capable de courage et
d'abnégation
à ce moment là il ne survit pas et c'est
parce qu'il est confronté à cette
nécessité de la survie que l'homme
allait telle nature et vertueux selon
rousseau il n'est pas vertueux du fait
d'une élection divine
il est vertueux du fait de sa condition
il est vertueux du fait de ses
conditions matérielles d'existence et
cette nudité de l'homme à l'état de
nature
le fait que l'homme soit littéralement
sans connaissance sans culture sans
intelligence technique là pour os n'est
pas un handicap c'est au contraire une
force parce que c'est la force de
l'homme pur et l'impur chez rousseau
c'est l'homme qui est dépouillée de tous
les artifices culturel de tous les
artifices sociaux idéologiques ou
politiques qui vont donner un certain
zone un sentiment de supériorité
un sentiment d'être les maîtres du monde
un sentiment d'être plus fort que la
nature et ça c'est quelque chose que
vous saurez que ce totalement ça fait
partie selon lui de ce vice de l'homme
moderne qui pour se donner une valeur
supérieure à sa valeur réelle va
s'imaginer que ses connaissances le
place au dessus du monde et ça c'est un
petit peu l'idée qu'on retrouvait chez
descartes lorsqu'il disait que l'homme
devait se faire comme maître et
possesseur de la nature comme maître et
possesseur de la nature
ça signifie que en vertu de son
intelligence en vertu de sa capacité de
compréhension du monde
l'homme peut s'émanciper des contraintes
de la nature et peut l'exploiter à son
profit
rousseau c'est une totale illusion mais
une illusion mortifère une illusion
funeste parce que cette illusion de
toute puissance de l'homme sur la nature
selon au saut va le conduire à sa perte
cette illusion va le conduire à la
déchéance
alors oui c'est un discours extrêmement
radical mais cette radicalité a pour
avantage de reposer la question du
progrès qu'est ce qu'on appelle le
progrès et c'est vrai que c'est une
question à laquelle il est difficile de
répondre parce que spontanément quand on
parle de progrès on a tendance à penser
soit au progrès matériel par exemple aux
progrès technologiques
on a aussi tendance à penser aux progrès
des libertés mais on pense très rarement
aux progrès de la vertu on pense très
rarement aux progrès moral et c'est
justement ça que veut dire rousseau
c'est que le progrès en soi ça ne veut
rien dire
la question c'est de quel progrès par le
ton est ce que le fait d'avoir remplacé
le combat physique par des poursuites
judiciaires par des calomnies par des
stratégies
est-ce que ça c'est vraiment le progrès
est ce qu'on peut parler de progrès
lorsqu'on a affaire à de la fourberie
lorsqu'on a affaire au règne de la
représentation c'est la question que
pose au saut est-ce qu'on peut encore
parler de progrès
alors évidemment pour rousseau c'est une
question rhétorique sa réponse est toute
faite
on peut pas parler de progrès ou en tout
cas on ne peut pas confondre on peut pas
associer le progrès des connaissances
avec le progrès moral ou sous nous dit
qu'à mesure que l'humanité progressé sur
le plan des connaissances elle régresser
sur le plan moral et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant d'illustrer sa part une
distinction conceptuel que fait rousseau
dans son oeuvre qui est la distinction
entre l'amour de soi et l'amour propre
aujourd'hui si on emploie l'expression
d' amour de soi on va penser qu'on fait
référence justement à une forme
d'égoïsme à une forme d'égocentrisme
alors qu'en fait pour rousseau c'est le
contraire l'amour de soi c'est tout
simplement l'attachement à sa propre vie
c'est le désir de persévérer dans sa vie
c'est ce qu'on appellerait l'instinct de
conservation et selon rousseau cet
instinct de conservation
il produit naturellement de l'empathie
il produit naturellement de la
compassion pour autrui et d'ailleurs
c'est quelque chose qui peut aujourd'hui
se justifier sur le plan scientifique
par la mise en évidence des neurones
miroirs les neurones miroirs qui font
que lorsque l'on va avoir quelques uns
souffrir on va reconnaître sur son
visage par exemple les signes de la
souffrance qu'ils vont nous ramener à
notre propre expérience de la souffrance
donc une certaine manière les neurones
miroirs valide la thèse de rousseau sur
la compassion naturelle de l'être humain
nous ne sommes pas naturellement
égoïstes nous ne voulons pas le mal
d'autrui nous ne voulons pas que l'autre
souffre nous voulons simplement nous
conserver dans la vie et éviter la
souffrance
donc ça c'est l'amour de soi et rousseau
oppose donc l'amour de soi à l'amour
propre et l'amour propre c'est quoi bien
c'est l'orgueil
c'est l'ego c'est ce qui fait qu'on veut
être au dessus de l'autre qu'on va être
meilleure que l'autre qu'on veut écraser
l'autre c'est ça l'amour propre
l'amour propre c'est ne pas accepter que
quelqu'un fasse quelque chose mieux que
nous parce que ça lui donne le sentiment
d'une perte de valeur de soi ça nous
donne l'impression d'une diminution de
la valeur de soi
et ce sentiment nous dit rousseau ce
n'est pas un sentiment naturel d'un
sentiment culturelle c'est un sentiment
lié à notre condition d'individus qui
vivent en société qui vivent dans la
civilisation qui vivent dans la
comparaison permanente qui fait que la
stratégie la ruse on remplaçait la force
et la vigueur
c'est ça l'amour propre donc vous voyez
on a bien affaire à deux anthropologie
totalement opposé l'anthropologie
pessimiste d'europe ce qui repose sur
l'idée que l'homme est naturellement
égoïste est mauvais et l'anthropologie
optimiste de rousseau qui part du
principe que l'homme est naturellement
bon et bienveillant alors je ferai quand
même une petite parenthèse là dessus
parce que de nombreux spécialistes de
rousseau vous diront ils ont raison que
rousseau ne dit pas à proprement parler
que l'homme est naturellement bon mais
l'homme est naturellement innocent et le
moins innocent est intéressant parce que
timo logiquement ça veut dire qui ne
nuit par qui ne cherche pas à faire du
mal c'est ça innocent c'est l'absence de
nos sens donc il ne s'agit pas de dire
que l'homme est bon au sens moderne de
généreux ou de serviable ou peu importe
c'est de dire que l'homme est d'abord
attaché à la conservation de soi et
qu'il considère l'autre comme sont
légales comme sont semblables qui est
également attaché à la conservation de
soi
l'homme à l'état de nature par exemple
ne va pas provoquer des conflits sans
raison l'homme à l'état de nature ne va
pas créer un conflit pour en tirer un
intérêt ne va pas chercher à créer des
intrigues politiques pour augmenter son
pouvoir pour augmenter son emprise et sa
capacité de domination sur les autres
l'homme à la nature va se contenter de
survivre et parce que c'est son seul
horizon parce que c'est son seul
objectif bien n'a aucun intérêt à faire
du mal aux autres
il n'a aucun intérêt à vouloir se
construire une image de soi
il n'a aucun intérêt à vouloir
entretenir une réputation qui ne lui
apportera strictement rien dans la
nature
c'est ça qui fait dire à rousseau que
l'homme est naturellement bon il est bon
au sens où il est animé que par l'amour
de soi et par l'amour de la vie alors
ici j'aimerais développer un peu sur la
question des conventions sociales que
rousseau critique fortement et
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui lui
est très souvent reproché le fait que
rousseau n'accorde aucun crédit aucune
valeur aux règles et aux conventions
sociales pourra prendre un exemple
concret n'est tous c'est celui de la
politesse lorsqu'on est enfant nos
parents nous apprennent la politesse
nous apprennent à dire merci à dire s'il
vous plaît et pourquoi est ce qu'on
apprend la politesse bien tout
simplement pour s'intégrer à la
communauté parce que lorsqu'on vit en
communauté on est obligé de tenir compte
de l'autre on ne peut pas vivre comme si
on était seul au monde donc à première
vue on pourrait dire que les règles de
politesse vont justement à l'encontre de
l'égoïsme que dénonce rousseau on dira
que la politesse c'est ce qui fait qu'on
va accorder à l'autre le droit d'exister
accordées à l'autre la reconnaissance de
son existence
c'est ça la politesse bien pour rousseau
non pour au saut la politesse ce n'est
qu'un habillage culturel de l'hypocrisie
politesse c'est du vent politesse c'est
de la comédie
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant parce que
l'étymologie du mot politesse c'est
police qui en grec signifie la cité
c'est à dire la communauté la société
donc la politesse c'est ce dont nous
avons besoin pour pouvoir vivre en
communauté
il est évident que comme le disait freud
si nous laissions libre cours à nos
pulsions violentes nos pulsions
agressives nos pulsions sexuelles et à
la vie en communauté serait tout
simplement impossible
on ne pourrait pas coexister les uns
avec les autres imaginer le genre de
scènes auxquelles ça pourrait donner
lieu dans la rue si chacun n'avaient en
vue que la satisfaction de son désir
pulsionnel ça deviendrait assez
rapidement ingérable
donc la politesse va faire effet de
coussin amortisseur dans notre rapport à
l'autre nous permettre d'entrer en
rapport avec l'autre de manière non
conflictuelle mais si pour rousseau
cette politesse n'a pas de valeur c'est
parce que le sentiment qu'ils devraient
se trouver à l'origine de la politesse à
savoir la bienveillance n'existe pas
dans l'état social en tout cas n'existe
pas comme dans l'état de nature n'existe
pas de manière spontanée de manière
authentique la bienveillance qui
transparaît dans la politesse n'est
qu'une bienveillance de façade n'est
qu'une bienveillance opportuniste qui ne
traduit pas la réalité de notre
sentiment envers l'autre et là j'ai
voulu en un petit extrait du discours
sur les sciences et des arts ce site qui
serait doux de vivre parmi nous si la
contenance extérieur était toujours
l'image des dispositions du coeur si la
décence et est la vertu sino maxi nous
servait de règles si la véritable
philosophie était inséparable du titre
de philosophes mais tant de qualités
vont trop rarement ensemble et la vertu
ne march again en si grande pompe la
vertu de marchegay rend ces grandes
pompes ça veut dire que la vertu n'a pas
besoin de s'afficher la vertu n'a pas
besoin de se démontrer n'a pas besoin
d'être en représentation
c'est ça que ça veut dire la vertu n'a
pas besoin d'être en représentation
car à partir du moment où on met la
vertu en représentation elle cesse
d'être la vertu elle devient de la
comédie sociale elle devient de
l'apparat elle devient du faux c'est
vraiment ça que combat rousseau c'est
cette hypocrisie sociale qui fait qu'on
va garder la forme de la bienveillance
mais pas l'intention de la bienveillance
on va garder l'habillage de la bonté
mais pas les langes labonté et ça c'est
très important
c'est très important parce que ça permet
de comprendre que l'augmentation des
connaissances n'est pas forcément un
gage d'amélioration humaine
l'augmentation de la connaissance n'a
pas pour conséquence l'augmentation de
la vertu humaine et c'est pour ça qu'on
soit à cette manière très amer de
répondre aux reproches qui lui sont
faits d'avoir abandonné ses enfants à
l'assistance publique il explique en
gros que ceux qui lui font ce reproche
sont des personnes qui ne se soucie
absolument pas de savoir ce qui était
bon pour ces enfants sont des personnes
qui sont justement dans ce règles de la
représentation et dix considèrent qu'
abandonner ses enfants c'est être
quelqu'un d' indigne et sur la question
du rail de la représentation on peut
dire que vous souhaitez plutôt
visionnaire alors évidemment je vais
vous sortir l'éternel couplet sur les
réseaux sociaux dont la fonction est de
moins en moins social est de plus en
plus personnel c'est à dire de créer de
renvoyer aux autres une certaine image
de soi une image de soi qui correspond
au jugement que l'on veut recevoir ou en
tout cas à l'impression qu'on veut
renvoyer aux autres mais il n'a même pas
besoin d'aller jusqu'aux réseaux sociaux
il suffit parfois d'observer les
comportements entre collègues de travail
entre voisins ou même au sein des
cercles d'amis pour se rendre compte à
quel point le besoin d'être meilleur que
l'autre
ou en tout cas d'apparaître comme
meilleur que l'autre à quel point ce
sont là des ressorts de la vie moderne
et pour arriver sur la dernière ligne
droite de cette vidéo on peut dire que
rousseau nous amène à réinterroger le
concept même de civilisation qui ne met
en opposition avec ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la vie sauvage
alors je précise immédiatement que le
mot sauvage fait partie des mots dont on
a le plus galvaudé le sens lorsqu'on
entend le mot sauvage on pense
immédiatement à des êtres humains qui se
comporterait comme des animaux comme des
bêtes
donc on considère que le mot sauvage à
quelque chose de très péjoratif pour ne
pas dire déshumanisant alors il faut
savoir qui étymologiquement le mot
sauvage signifie simplement qui a grandi
dans la nature qui s'est développée à
l'écart de toute intervention humaine à
l'écart de toute influence de la société
c'est là pour ça qu'on parle de plantes
sauvages ou de fruits sauvages
c'est-à-dire des végétaux qui n'ont pas
été plantés par les hommes
c'est ça la signification originelle du
mot sauvage et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
dit montaigne dans ses essais dans le
chapitre sur les cannibales dans le
chapitre des coches où montaigne
explique que les amérindiens sont
sauvages au sens où certains fruits sont
sauvages c'est à dire ils n'ont pas été
altérées ils n'ont pas été dégradées par
la main de l'homme
une plante sauvage c'est une plante qui
a poussé son tuteur autrement dit qui
n'a pas été dévié de sa trajectoire
naturelle par un artifice par une
intervention artificiel un twitter c'est
une intervention artificiel pour que la
plante pousse de manière parfaitement
verticale c'est ça le rôle du tout de la
même façon
l'éducation c'est faire grandir c'est
faire pousser à un être humain en le
conformant un certain nombre de codes à
certain nombre de conventions à un
certain nombre d' usage comme la
politesse qui sont les instruments
sociaux de la coexistence et ses cotes
sont à la fois la condition de
possibilité de la vie sociale mais sont
aussi ceux qui va détourner l'homme de
sa condition originelle ce qui va lui
faire perdre son authenticité sa vertus
naturelles sa compassion naturelle et
qui va faire naître jalousie qui va
faire naître comparaison qui va faire
naître concurrence qui va faire naître
le conflit et la rivalité et qui loin de
mettre un terme à la guerre de tous
entre tous va tout simplement lui donner
une autre forme
une forme poli une forme socialement
acceptable une forme déguisée
je terminerai cette vidéo en vous citant
un extrait un petit peu plus long du
discours sur les sciences et les arts
je cite plus d'amitié sincère plus
destine réel plus de confiance fondée
les soupçons les ombrages les craintes
la froideur la réserve la haine la
trahison se cacheront sens c'est sous ce
voile uniforme et perfide de politesse
sous cette urbanité si vanté que nous
devons lumière de notre siècle on ne
procédera plupart des jurons le nom du
maître de l'univers mais on n'insulte
rappard des blasphèmes sans que nos
oreilles scrupuleuse en soient offensés
on ne vendra pas son propre mérite mais
au rabais sera celui d'autrui on outrage
rap grossièrement son ennemi mais on le
calomnie rats avec adresse les aides
nationales s'éteindront mais ce sera
avec l'amour de la patrie à l'ignorance
méprisé on substituera un dangereux
pyrrhonisme il y aura des excès proscrit
davis déshonoré mais d'autres seront
décorés du nom de vertu il faudra ou les
avoirs ou les affecter ventraq qui
voudra la sobriété des sages du temps je
n'y vois pour moi un raffinement
d'intempérance autant indigne de mon
éloge que leur artificieuse simplicité
[Musique]
et
oh
à